there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right yet to fail all the same
read it
run from it Dustin's still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
engage your defenses
and get this manna sheet
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalancing universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
are you guys a verybody it's finally
here time to freak out there was an idea
you release a trailer to break the
Internet The Avengers infinity war
trailer if you're just finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything there's gonna be a
giveaway stuff happening at the end of
the video I'll explain but let's just
start with the beginning first and go
through this shop buy a shot the speech
that Nick Fury is giving at the
beginning of the trailer then each of
the separate Avengers character starts
giving like they each get a line from
that dialogue is when Nick Fury was
originally explaining The Avengers
initiative to them after Coulson died in
the first Avengers film there was an
idea but you start in outer space on
earth then you see dr. Strange's sanctum
sanctorum and it looks like Hulk crashes
through it and they're just like what
the hell is going on dr. Bruce Banner
how did you wind up here you see Tony
Stark and it seems like he's still
having nightmares ever since Scarlet
Witch gave him that vision of the
shatori and all the dead Avengers you
jumped to Scarlet Witch envision who is
now looking like a normal man but you
still see the mind gem in his forehead
but just remember he can make himself
look like whatever he wants there's a
big rumor that they might even be doing
a version of their children in Avengers
4 based on a casting notice and there'll
be some crazy twist behind it because
the only children that vision should be
able to have are ones that he makes for
himself there was a whole comic book
about it like he makes himself a family
you jump to Thor who's on the Milano and
is still missing his eye just letting
you know that he's going to be pirate
Thor for a little while longer because
of that big Vanity Fair spread people
are like what's up with the scar why
does he have the hammer again so this
just provides you with a little bit of
continuity from the post-credits scene
in thor ragnarok you just see him
looking at what looks like a dead planet
maybe this is still an Asgardian space
like he's looking down on it like oh man
that just happened that's right
my homeworld just got blown up you see
Hulk reunited with Black Widow and a
piece of Hulk Buster this might be
happening later in the film so what
might end up happening is is when he
Asha's through the sanctum sanctorum
might be during a big battle in New York
or it's always possible that when he
crashes back to earth that's where he
lands but remember that Wakanda is on
the other side of the earth from the
sanctum sanctorum but because he's
Doctor Strange he can portal them
anywhere in an instant that he wants so
it's not like travel is a big problem
for them then you finally get the Thanos
dialogue in time you will know what it
is to lose if you think his speech
sounds a little Baroque a little bit old
it just because he talks the way he
talks during the classic Thanos comics
and it's meant to be this grand
Shakespearean villain type of way so he
doesn't talk like a normal villain with
talk in modern films but this scene
provides a little bit of continuity with
Hulk crashing through the sanctum
sanctorum so you see Iron Man standing
here in the new version of his costume
which looks like it just forms around
him extremity I'll like he wears little
bits of it so he can walk around in that
jacket but he can manifest it on command
spider-man on the other hand in the new
version of the costume looks like he has
to actually put most of it on but it
does seem like some of it actually does
form around him a little bit I love the
way spider-man's spidey sense just goes
off the charts
and that's how he knows is going
down like he has no idea what's going on
with a nose they haven't told him
anything about the Infinity stones but
he sees this and just knows that
something is coming turns his head and
then sees Thanos his ship over New York
so if it wasn't clear that is one of his
ships but it's not the same ship from
the end of Thor Ragnarok
that was called sanctuary 2 this might
be a drop ship that just breaks off from
that when he comes down to planets you
get a shot from his perspective up in
the sky looking down it looks like they
just started to rain down on New York
City and all the Avengers are looking up
like oh it's on now you get a
little bit better shot of his arc
reactor
you see Wong and Doctor Strange just
ready to throw down so it's almost like
someone's getting ready to land this
actually seems like Loki on a different
planet these people could be from earth
that they could be from somewhere else
but he does have the tesseract confirmed
that he stole it at the end of thor
ragnarok then he finally portals in you
can run from it but destiny still
arrives like he is there
Destinee that's the way he feels about
his mission like it's preordained he has
to do it is this imperative that's why
there's been a story called Thanos
imperative but it's not quite the same
thing as what they're doing in this
movie we get a shot of Thor in space
while we start getting the Black Panther
dialogue so obviously they're jumping
around a time quite a bit this just
looks like one of the santoses orbital
platforms either for portaling people in
or just getting ready to attack the
earth so it just looks like Thor's
trying to take down one of his big
weapons
he says engage all defences while we get
the shot at Proxima midnight throwing
her spear in Captain America catching it
but also says get this man of shield so
you know that he's talking about Captain
America get him a new shield so all
that's happening in a separate scene
from what's happening with Proxima
midnight here so two completely
different parts of the film but we
finally see the black order coming after
the infinity gems like them laying in
tewevision we see that US has the space
gem so that's how he portals in you see
Scarlet Witch some of this is the
footage that I broke down earlier this
Monday is basically the vision attack
Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive
coming after vision we see a shot of the
Hulkbuster in Wakanda this might be from
when Hulk first comes back or when
they're gearing up for Matt attack from
the Black Order like holy I'm gonna
need this even though the Hulk is back
and I might need it for him too you get
a shot of the outriders who sort of like
fan OSes dogs of war they're like a
subgroup
from the Black Order the sort of
genetically engineered them to go burrow
into people's minds and get information
then come back they're just sort of like
this animalistic thing to have these
telepathic abilities but I like the way
they have this Panther like quality to
them because they're in Wakanda fighting
the Black Panther in his forces so they
have to fight an army of them up which
sort of explains that Thanos looking
like he has the Space Jam just making
spider-man eat some he is going to
feel that tomorrow but it's interesting
to note how much more powerful this
version of the suit is so he will
survive it plus he does have a healing
factor not a Wolverine level healing
factor but it'll still help him heal up
a little bit faster I love this shot of
the Infinity Gauntlet - because you see
vision with the yellow gem in his eye
but you don't see that in thanasis
gauntlet here she's putting them in the
Infinity Gauntlet so he
as blue in purple meaning that he has
the power gem in now the space gem so
just two right now shot of the new Iron
Man costume I love the dialogue here
this has been in a couple of the trailer
videos that I've done before like from
the Comic Con footage because that is
basically the Comic Con footage fun
isn't usually something that I consider
when balancing the universe but this is
going to put a smile on my face you get
that nice HD shot of the Infinity
Gauntlet and then Thanos going after
Iron Man who there's just no way that
his suit is going to be able to match
stano's Thanos without any of the
infinity gems is still powerful enough
to pound Thor who just got a major power
upgrade during Ragnarok this actually
all seems like it's happening somewhere
besides earth like it's almost on an
asteroid in outer space somewhere this
isn't the beginning of that outrider
attack Winter Soldier has finally been
thawed we knew about this because it was
also in the Comic Con trailer the suit
that black panther is wearing is the
same suit that Sheree gives him during
the course of the black panther trailer
just like the newest version of the suit
so it looks like Team Captain America
from Civil War is all down in Wakanda
with the addition of the Hulk a little
bit away they in the trailer - who the
hell are you guys and then mantis is
just like hello hey how's it going just
raises her hand real quietly this is
from the scene right after he faced
plants on the windshield of the Milano
in outer space in rocket is like wipers
wipers so they didn't cut down that
Comic Con footage just a little bit but
they added in a little bit more but just
let me know what part of you guys
freaking out about the most what do you
think about the new Spider Man suit what
do you think about the new Iron Man suit
and what do you think about the idea
that Thanos only has two of the Infinity
stones during what looks like one of the
later battles in the film like Captain
America Winter Soldier is sort of this
political thriller this is going to be
more of a heist movie just because
they're doing Thanos quest and that's
him going around collecting all the gems
in the comics it was a little bit
different the last gem the sixth one was
actually from the Grand Master so I
think what they might do is they might
save him collecting all six for the
fourth Avengers film and we'll just see
him with most of the gems at the end of
this film based on this footage in the
timeline that they present in the fact
that he only has a
all of the gems later in the film when
do you think that we're going to see
that soul gem pop up but as for dead
Avengers honestly I think that if we're
gonna see dead Avengers we won't see
that till the fourth Avengers film so
this is gonna be one of those Avengers
films where you see grown men cry
because Thanos is so badass and kicks
their butts so badly there's a new round
of that IMAX take a giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Nick Boleo please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll announce a new winner when
I post new infinity war so obviously
there's so many different things we have
to talk about just let me know what you
want my next infinity war video to be
about so there's a bunch of other stuff
to get through just make sure you have
alerts turned on so you don't miss any
of the videos because there's also Star
Wars stuff that's coming really soon
- but click here to learn all about
their phase 4 interview in the Marvel
cosmic universe they were talking about
earlier this week and you can click here
for my videos from the big DC TV
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight